In the US, media reports say that US President Donald Trump...
...spoke with Russian President Vladimir Putin over the phone.
Among the topics the two leaders discussed...
...was the Mueller report on Russian interference in US elections.
In Venezuela, opposition leader Juan Guaido held a news conference with lawmakers in Caracas...
...after he called for peaceful demonstrations at army bases.
In India, Cyclone Fani has made landfall near the eastern city of Puri.
A grade 5 storm, it's replete with heavy rain and wind gusting to 205 kilometers per hour.
Two people have died from the storm.
A historic "loya jirga" peace summit in Kabul ends with delegates from across Afghanistan...
...demanding an immediate and permanent ceasefire.
Lastly, in Uganda, as World Press Freedom Day was celebrated,...
...television and radio stations are being targeted...
...over coverage of an opposition figure's appearance in court.